we begin this morning with breaking news
overnight from texas where democrats
blocked a republican move
to tighten the state's voting laws by
boycotting the final minutes
of the legislative session yeah the
sweeping legislation was created after
former president trump's repeated false
claims of voter fraud in 2020
christina rafini is at the white house
where president biden has called the
proposed law wrong
and un-american christina what exactly
happened in texas last night
good morning jericho well with the clock
ticking down democrats got a text
message from their caucus leader telling
them to leave the chamber
and they did preventing a quorum
republicans needed to hold the vote and
stopping the bill
at least for now this bill
in a dramatic late night maneuver
democrats blocked the vote on texas
senate bill
7 just before its midnight deadline we
killed
that bill and railed against last minute
provisions added to the bill behind
closed doors
including making it easier for judges to
throw out election results based on the
allegation of fraud
the bill is one of the most restrictive
in the country it bans drive-through
and 24-hour voting makes it illegal for
counties to send unsolicited absentee
ballots
adds new id requirements for those
ballots and limits polling hours
even during early voting delaying the
start until 1pm
on sundays a time that democrats argue
specifically targets after church voter
drives in african-american communities
souls to the polls is sacred
republicans were determined to take that
away meanwhile drive-through and 24-hour
voting
popular with minority communities were
used for the first time last year in
harris county
which includes increasingly diverse
houston where president biden won
by 13 points republicans say the
legislation is necessary to protect the
integrity of the voting system
even though there were no major
instances of fraud reported in texas
in the last election this may be more of
an optics issue
restoring confidence with with the
american people
and in my state you actually do believe
there was tremendous
optics over evidence republicans kept
every one of their 23 house seats in
2020
and president trump won the state with
52 percent of the vote
no governor greg abbott has said this is
not over and he will call legislators
back for a special session
to vote on the bill later this year a
fight for certain in texas christina
thank you